one doesn't think of mount charleston
without noting griffith peak and mary
jane falls both named for the
prestigious family who helped shape las
vegas into the bustling city it is today
and developed much of kyle canyon in the
early 1900s here's a look back at its
beginnings and some historic photos
thanks to bob stoldahl the chairman of
the city of las vegas historic
preservation board
well i worked there i remember some of
the people that came up during the time
i worked there and the romances that
took place bob stold started collecting
old photos of the earlier years of mount
charleston lodge when he started working
as a janitor there in 1961. when i
graduated from las vegas high school it
was an opportunity to learn to become a
bartender he says mount charleston as a
recreational facility really began in
1905 after e.w griffith and his family
created griffith's camp which over the
years expanded into a dude ranch where
people would stay to get their divorce
dude ranches were really just a place
where you could spend your six weeks
that you had to have quote residency in
in las vegas at one point it was known
as charleston park then the charleston
park lodge and casino and at one point
the casino was even called the ponderosa
post world war ii that the frontier
hotel leaked the entire area at least
the lodge and the cabin and they were
successful because they knew how to run
a hotel casino and take care of visitors
and and all of that that was in
1948 and they operated for for a while
then there was a change of hands through
all that los vegas were drawn to the
wonderfulness of mount charleston but in
1961 a fire destroyed the lodge the
owners of the hacienda resort owned the
lodge at the time and were determined to
rebuild construction began in 1962 and
several years later the restaurant and
lounge were added the orkut family took
over operations and in 1994 added more
than a dozen cabins in 2018 it was sold
to the ellis family which also owned the
ellis island casino in las vegas
many valley residents of course have
such fond memories of the lodge please
share them with us you can send your
photos to pixset's pix
8newsnow.com we've been sharing some of
these thank you kathy here's just a few
that you and kimberly here are sharing
with us today